[Music]
hey what's up everyone
welcome to culture binge the wisecrack
podcast where we get
all up in that cultural zeitgeist i'm
michael and joined as always by
wisecrack writer serbie serbi how are
you this fine morning
hi i'm well how are you good um
and the tony stark of the wisecrack
cinematic universe
alec alec how are you today hey i'm good
awesome um well as always we have lots
to get into
uh we'll talk a little bit about the the
hell
or the joy or the pain of working
remotely we're gonna get into some
recent
drama around only fans uh and then we'll
talk a little bit about how
listening to new music can make your
brain stronger
but first we need to start by talking
about the little things that are either
bringing lots of joy
or mounds of pain to our life slaps and
chaps
uh serbia as always let's start with you
what is slapping
and chatting these days for you so what
slaps is
r and j toffee so that's
r and j toffee yeah it's not sponsored
this slap is not sponsored by rnj toffee
but i'm about to go into a really deep
love letter to rnj toffee
it's a family owned confectionary based
in northern california
and they have the best toffee it's so
delicious it has the most incredible
texture and flavor
when my friend had knee surgery last
year i sent her some toffee
and she couldn't get over how buttery
and delicious it is
um and i had completely forgotten about
them until last week when i received a
marketing email
uh saying that their online stores open
and i was like oh my god
rjtoffees.com so anyway if you like
toffee as much as i do check out
rjtoffees.com
um and i really want to support them
because it sounds super sponsored
sound sponsored but it's not but i i
really want to support them because they
have the best topi and because of the
pandemic i'm afraid that they're gonna
like close up shop and it like fills me
with sadness and i'm like no
or you got two emails from long time
listeners that say that because of the
ingrained sponsored content they will no
longer be listening to the show
so good job i only want to be sponsored
by klm
and then what chaps is yeah west coast
is on fire
yeah yeah 2020 hell of a ride yeah
um that's so much fun uh well nothing
else to say about that that won't get
super depressing alec what is slabbing
you having for you
uh i mean it's an easy one but thank you
rapidpoly for donating says
we love your content don't know who we
is maybe it's a joint uh donation
uh what slaps is a while ago
i bought um a kobo which is an e-reader
it's a knock-off kindle whatever you
want to call it and i've just been
like somehow it's gamified my brain
until like i'm reading
a thousand percent more than i've ever
read i've got like 18 books on my
overdrive hold list at the library and
i'm just like [ __ ] i have to read all
these books before they expire because
then i'll have to wait again
and uh it's somewhat like addictive but
also i've just learned a lot so
hooray for ebooks and you find yourself
able to keep up with that you're not
getting overwhelmed by
all the options and and not reading
anything at all
uh no because i mean no i have a very
long wait list
uh that like is slowly sort of coming in
and there will be times where it's like
i don't have time to read that book i'm
not reading it but i think there's like
three or four things if i read two of
them before the two weeks expires the
three weeks expires that i have to read
it i will be very proud of myself
uh what chaps
i actually forgot what did i write oh i
still haven't won a single [ __ ] game
of fall guys
that hurts my feelings i don't know a
lot about it but i've watched you play
it twice
and you're good but it seems like at the
end stages you always kind of struggle a
bit and get a little bit overwhelmed
yeah that's true it's very true um i
will just say if you do want to ever
watch alex play fall guys um
this is not uh sponsored content but
we've been uh
doing these live stream hangouts on our
patreon where alec plays fall guys and
the rest of us
talk uh about stuff we're working on so
you know join our patreon et cetera et
cetera
um okay so slap some jobs for me a slaps
this might be a little too like earnest
but i don't know i felt warm inside this
weekend because i experienced some
people helping people type stuff
because of fires and heat waves where i
live
i got to about like 115 on sunday
um and uh i went out to there was like a
there's an organization in los angeles i
like a lot that
was giving out both water and setting up
a tie-dye shirt station two things i
love helping people with water and
tie-dye
i'm giving you water frozen water
bottles to give out people that are
unhoused in the neighborhood
um and while going out and giving waters
to people i kept
running into other groups that were like
overlapping so it was like the problem
of too many people in my area of los
angeles that wanted to go out and like
help their neighbors who were trying to
stay alive in 115 degree heat
and made me feel good just at least i
mean it felt bad that
there was 115 degree heat and people
have to live outside felt good that
people were helping people so that was
good
um chaps wise i'm gonna go hyper
specific here i had a list of chaps
because that's how negative i am but the
one i'm going to pick is
one of my favorite places in the world a
restaurant in the koreatown neighborhood
of los angeles called beverly sun tofu
house
a place that was featured on one of the
first la episodes
that anthony bourdain ever did announced
two days ago that they are closing down
for good
they've been operational for around 30
years they're the first people that
brought a certain type of
korean soup dish to los angeles and it's
one of the first places
i'm the first place i ever ate at in the
koreatown neighborhood of los angeles a
neighborhood that
i don't want to say changed my life but
but has been very important
to me and has been a gateway into me
getting interested in learning about
uh both the the food and the the culture
in general of
of korea so it just bums me out and in
general it bums me out that we're
hearing
more and more about restaurants and
businesses closing down
because of coba 19 and it sucks and
while it's not our personal
responsibility to keep stuff open i'm
just like
if you have the money to do it take it
get some food from from struggling
restaurants that you'll like a lot i
don't know and let's like not eat a
chain restaurants because they're going
to be fine
sorry that was too much go to taco bell
i guess um but that's that for me
i'm really excited to hear about the
restaurant yeah the only hope is the
daughters of the woman who originally
started it said they're not
closing off the possibility of one day
reopening so fingers crossed
um and if you do live in in los angeles
i think they're
for another week or two you can still
take out from them so why not but it
might be too sad
um but speaking of supporting workers
and businesses
that are struggling right now giving
money directly to the people who are
giving
food and content to you serbia you're
gonna talk to us a little bit about some
recent drama
and only fans um on only fans and maybe
when we get into this as well
i'll ask you that you give everyone a
rundown of what only fans is just in
case they're not familiar with it
yes here's a question if you're not
chronically on twitter
like do i know about only fans because
i'm chronically on twitter or do most
people know about this
i don't know about it well now you but
now
now i do but i didn't know about it um
and i am on twitter but chronically so
um yeah like where it's like a
neurological defect of your personality
quite often i although my i don't follow
a lot of people so that's
a possibility that i just well then tell
us what you've recently learned about
only fans
okay so first of all i need to create an
account that's what i've learned
um but also i've learned that
uh only fans is a subscription-based
content website where fans
can subscribe to exclusive content made
by their favorite creators
and anyone can upload their content and
monetize their influence so
like if you write if you're an artist
whatever you do you can upload your
content and since the beginning of the
pandemic
only fans has skyrocketed in popularity
for a couple of reasons
one it is natural that people are
looking for entertainment because
there's nothing else to do
and two many people have lost their jobs
due to covid19
so they're looking to earn some money
and
the platform is especially popular with
sex workers
because they can set boundaries they can
work in a safe environment
they can get to know their clients on
their terms and
they can work to destigmatize sex work
so all in all it's great
sex workers found a safe place to work
and now they have a primary source of
income that is reliable
and before joy our wonderful producer
suggested this topic
i hadn't heard of only fans or bella
thorne
and for those of you who don't know
bella thorne is an actress and model and
she was on
a disney channel show so recently
everything uh went to [ __ ] because bella
thorne
messed up only fans by joining the site
she made a million dollars in one day
and posted pictures of herself in a
bikini
she was eating a hot dog and sex workers
were
understandably upset about her joining
the site because she's
a celebrity she's well known she has
other
revenue streams available to her and
it's
important to note here too that i think
the bella thorne implied
she was going to post a nude at a 200
level
oh sorry i'm so sorry so the real
problem came in when
she said that she had a pay-per-view
image that was a fully
nude image and she listed it for two
hundred dollars
so people forked over two hundred
dollars expecting a nude image of her
but what they received was a picture of
bellathorne in her lingerie so
everyone requested refunds and
side note bella thorne has released her
nudes uh
in response to an extortion attempt so
they're
out there for free people didn't need to
pay 200 for them
um but anyway so during this public
outcry
only fans decides to change its
transaction terms so they lengthen
the payout time from seven days to 30
days
they place a limit on the amount that
fans can
tip a creator and they also placed
limits on the pay-per-view
prices because before you could set your
own price
so only fans denies that it changed the
transaction terms based on
the bella thorne experience but i mean
i think the average reasonable person
can assume that that's not
true so the effects of this are quite
detrimental to sex workers they
will make less money and not be paid as
quickly
they no longer have the autonomy in
setting their own prices they can't rely
on this
as their primary source of revenue and
bella thorne issued an apology saying
that she joined only fans
to quote remove the stigma behind sex
sex work and the negativity that
surrounds the word sex itself by
bringing a mainstream face to it
and she also said she wanted to do
research for a film
about sex workers so all in all
we all hate bella thorin
she angered the sex workers and we can't
stand for that anyway what do you think
what are your thoughts i think one thing
that's interesting too is the
she said the film she was working on and
i feel bad i forget the filmmaker's last
name it's sean
something as the the filmmaker made
tangerine and the florida project
who's like and if anything this is a
person who's made films in the past that
have featured
and and highlighted like actual sex
workers in particular in the movie
tangerine
um and she kind of she said that it was
to research a movie she was gonna make
with him and then as soon as this all
happened he put out a statement that was
like uh-uh
don't put this on me uh we maybe had a
conversation once but i'm not making
that movie
and i would never do this to like heard
sex workers
but in general yeah his response was
actually
actually like really cut her down and
and
so she he basically was like i spoke to
her about this about
creating a film in the far future and
suggested she
researched sex workers and talk to sex
workers
in a way that doesn't harm them like he
was very specific
and was like i did not tell her to do
this but yeah i think pretty simply
right this just like sucks
and it's a another example of this
problem recently
where it's higher level celebrities
infiltrating like
lower levels of entertainment work and
content production
and i think in a certain sense like
there's it's not that far removed from
the
from the fact that many a-list actors
are now in all the commercials where it
used to be a thing where like
there were commercial actors who could
make a living starting things like that
whereas now
you know you have like brie larson and
matthew mcconaughey in commercials for
various products
um yeah i think it just shows a lack of
awareness on bella thorne's part about
the idea that for a lot of people like
you pointed out serbia this is how they
make their income and it's a way that
they can
safely produce content in particular
adult content
that doesn't have to be mediated by like
sketchy websites
um or any dangerous like real life
situations or whatnot
so i think it just sucks and i think
it's i don't know it's sort of like a
wokeness gone wrong thing to a bella
thorne trying to act as if she was
uplifting or like normalizing the space
like very presumptuous
to say that like wow me former disney
star is gonna like make only fans good
it's like no it's fine like it didn't
need you
everyone is having a nice time it's sort
of like when like big celebrity shows up
at like an indie rock concert and they
think they're giving it cred but really
they're just killing the whole vibe
yeah i think i think kind of the
the performative woke apology of oh i'm
trying to lift people up but
the clear cynicism there and i also
think this is something that just
happens with
sort of powerful people a lot they do an
awful thing it's like oh i was trying to
help it's like if you're trying to help
there's lots of ways to do that that
aren't basically enriching yourself
but i also think like a similar dynamic
and it's i mean celebrities are a big
example but i think just like
powerful people in general they'll sort
of show up to a community
not really care about like the the they
want the community to cohere around them
so whether it's
some famous rocker showing up at an
indie concert
but i think in more banal ways like you
know
an actor or celebrity or just like a ceo
of a company showing up at a pta meeting
and be like listen kids i know how to
get things done
and you know we're going to run this
school my way or we're going to run only
fans my way or it's going to
sort of exist around my identity and
it's kind of just like uh
oh people like me i'm important
therefore i should be the vanguard of
this thing instead of
shutting the [ __ ] up and you know taking
a cue like listening to the people and
only fans instead of
you know drawing all this attention
also i i don't i took uh issue with her
statement that she was trying to
destigmatize sex and the words around
sex and stuff like
are we living in like 1910
like is there a stigma against on sex
and do we need to destigmatize it oh
yeah
i mean i think i think the stigma is
there especially around you know sex
work especially
do you think it is though it's kind of
like the generations he's speaking to
because i i don't know i like when i
talk about only fans you know it's a lot
of like
gen z millennial types who are very
active on like twitter and stuff like
that
i think they're not people who are
stigmatizing sex work like maybe like
you know boomers and and people that
wouldn't know of only fans anyways
i feel like if you go down to like you
know if someone has a friend
you know who's like i want to start
working at a strip club or
starting only fans their friends will be
like oh maybe you shouldn't do that like
that's
you know day class a that's not that's
not for people like us
uh or even you know i
have to imagine there's plenty of people
my age or your age or servies age
who when looking at a resume or might
sort of google someone that they're
thinking about hiring like oh they used
to do this or that i don't want to be
associated with that
i i think plenty of it's still there i
think it's dumb that it's there but i
think
it is very much there yeah i quick i
quickly
briefed at the chat and i i looked at
the chat i think i saw someone
mention this is sort of like a
gentrification thing and i think that's
a funny way to look at it as well like
the gentrification of only fans um
something that was
and i know the website has tons of
problems inherent but like the users
were enjoying
and now we have to have a not an a-list
person but like a hollywood celeb come
in and try to like
class the place up the same way that i
don't know like
starbucks and jimmy john's coming to a
neighborhood to like make it legitimate
normally in the process of ruining
businesses i would also suggest this the
same thing that happened with youtube
obviously there was no sex involved but
youtube used to be this great space
where there's all these cool indie
performers
and then youtube was like we need
[ __ ] american express's money
so let's get jimmy kimmel on here and
let's get you know
basically primetime tv and now
that's what the algorithm wants to push
youtube has been gentrified
everyone yeah is i think i saw i
mentioned i saw this in the chat too and
i only learned this over the weekend
that she has a channel but i mentioned
her when i talked about commercials is
brie larson the bella thorne of youtube
i don't know anything i mean i know she
started a channel
yeah all i know about brie larson is
she's in captain marvel and people
uh on the internet are mad at her for
doing her job
wow good actor though great actor i
i saw this one actor who created a
patreon page and that like weirded me
out
because i was like why do you need that
i don't understand
yeah i was like the time zach braff
tried to crowdfund a movie and was like
dog don't you have enough scrub
scrubs residuals to do whatever you want
like don't make us pay for garden state
too
but sorry that's moving away from the
topic
i think it's just kind of gross to me
when celebrities try to
cash in on these like independent like
like websites that try to lift up
independent artists who don't have other
have don't have access to things like
they don't have agents they don't have
sponsors they don't have things like
that
it's like let let those platforms exist
for independent creators
you can go on youtube and post like
yourself and
lip gloss sponsored for like and i just
think yeah
and in general just worries me like if
we don't have structures for
people that are making like not
mainstream art literature
or doing you know sex work that's that's
outside of like
you know the normative flows of of
capitalism or whatever
if we lose those spaces everything's
going to be the same
like if we don't have you know to if we
don't have like a website like bandcamp
then all we have are artists that can
afford to get you know point zero one
cent per song on spotify or whatever it
is
um so it is worrisome and it's just
worrisome too i think it also is just
another sign of how out of touch
a lot of higher level celebrities are
with
how the rest of us live and how a lot of
creative people
um you know make their living
so here's a question
is there fin dom on only fans and can
men do it can i thin dom some people
can i invade the space
yeah i mean you wouldn't be invading it
i think i mean it'd be a challenge if
you know anyone in the chat let us know
if you would let alec
find um you um and we're not going to
say what finn dom is let's no one can
say it if you want to know what it is
look it up
um i mean you could maybe get there on
only fans i feel like one of the points
or the nice thing about an only fans
model
is that let's say you have a very niche
interest specialty
ability all you need is a small group of
people that appreciate your thing
to you know make some coin off of that
which i think is nice so al i want to
say maybe there is a lane for you i want
to go through people's credit card
statements and shame them be like you
spent thirty dollars on postmates
twice a week come on it would really
just be like me convention about what i
find are your responsible purchases
oh that's pretty low level fin dominant
you gotta be like transferring large
sums of money and be like this is what
you deserve you bastard
yeah get off wall street bets give me
all your money and i'll just put it in
very safe
uh index funds yes which then transfer
directly into my student loan account
it's a it's a very jewish
wow well on that note um serbia any
final thoughts on
bella thorne and only fans wisecrack
stands with sex workers
shouts uh speak for myself as
representative of white scrap oh yeah i
don't know if anyone knows this survey
is the
pure representative of i'm the only why
is i am wisecrack
the spiritual embodiment of the entire
brand
yes so there you go uh finally i have
some
i have some well this is unrelated but i
have some shout outs to people in the
chat uh of course due to bites
who says uh just mack and i island fudge
in michigan is a is a good option for
your
we also got dorian nance who says
interesting how
a bunch of thirsty guys are paying for
the girlfriend experience
and cracked prince nez don't have time
to tune in today but you are a wonderful
bunch
gratitude and love thank you so much
those are such nice things
that's great um so before we get into
remote work stuff alec i gotta say i saw
you move for a second and i noticed
something on your shirt
what what you wearing bud oh i got i got
the new wisecrack shirt
whoa oh donkey it's a t-shirt i actually
can't really i got to move the thing to
make sure that i'm fully
sure wow look at that move
wow model
go to wisecrack.store and check it out
it's cool and it's a way to support us
um and we won't ruin anyone's livelihood
that i know of
we will not um and yeah and just uh
we'll we'll be showing
y'all some new stuff soon this is sort
of a little hint but a few of us have
been
working on new merch it's not coming
from some weird
corporate headquarters it's a few of us
who are trying to think about what sort
of stuff we like what we think you might
like um
alex wearing one of the new shirts we're
gonna have some new stuff coming out so
you can check out the store um is it is
it just wisecrack store
no it's wisecrack.store we're also
working on a mug that the the color's a
little
messed up but i'm very excited about it
regardless we're going to fix the color
yeah oh yeah i should have brought mine
i'm having a lot of trouble centering it
and it's blue on the inside
and i had to fight michael about that
because he doesn't like inside colors
i think it's i think inside color's in a
mug or gross i don't wanna it's gonna
make if i put coffee
in a mug with an inside color it's gonna
make it look murky and then i'm gonna be
thinking
is there algae in my cup i just want to
wash your cups coffee
i don't who washes their cups grow up
you know
okay um so i know well speaking of not
having to wash my cups
because i no longer work in an office
space where people can
judge my disgusting habits um alec
what's going on with remote work how is
it changing
business work culture our lives all the
above
uh so there's this really cool article
on medium by steve levine called remote
work is killing the hidden trillion
dollar office economy
uh previously i've talked about just
kind of hypothesized about
how remote work is changing our
neighborhoods we're not commuting all
the time and commuting is a horrible
soul-crushing experience
people seem more engaged with their
communities maybe uh but this
specifically is about basically there's
a
trillion dollar economy around like
serving office workers
uh let me double check it's trillion i'm
going to read some some things uh
some things from this article so i'm not
talking about my ass but um
a ton of ton a ton of the economy goes
to
getting office workers their bacon egg
and cheeses and their coffee and getting
their shoes shined and
you know business travel and stuff like
that and so here's the first uh
here's a paragraph from the article in
the five months since the coronavirus
forced a lockdown of u.s businesses
economists have focused much attention
on the devastation of mom and pop
businesses brick and mortar shops bars
and restaurants and massive chains
but they have mostly overlooked a
looming threat to vastly larger and more
consequential galaxy of businesses
one worth trillions of dollars boom i
was right a year in gdp and revolving
around a single much under-appreciated
economic actor the white-collar office
worker
it goes on to say these workers shopped
at small businesses like silva's shoe
repair shop
dry cleaners gyms food carts forests and
pharmacies but they're also among the
most vital customers and source of
revenue for a slew of larger less of not
obvious businesses
food delivery companies like grubhub and
ubereats and companies like xerox
the maker of printing supplies amid
covid19 workwear destinations brooks
brother and j.crew have filed for
bankruptcy protection
with brooks brothers selling itself last
month and on its quarterly earnings call
in late july
starbucks attributed the loss of some 2
billion a year on
the deserted urban office corridors um
other things that have been affected are
hotels
airlines uh real estate uh businesses
are canceling their
their leases uh in places like midtown
manhattan obviously other sort of
business centers in other cities
um restaurants with happy hours
uh and i don't i can't speak for every
city but i know
like midtown manhattan is basically
nobody lives there it's only office
buildings and
every single restaurant bar there really
caters to these
these people and it's not like living in
the suburbs where there's other sources
of people
traveling through midtown there so i
imagine there's other places
uh like that in other cities um
but it also just kind of reminded me of
uh
david graber talks about the service
economy r.i.p david graber he just died
yeah uh he talks about the service
economy and talks about
this uh there's sort of like a an old
joke
uh it's a 19th century joke about an
island where people make a living by
doing each other's laundry
uh and the the basic idea is our service
economy is this to various other degrees
right we're too busy to do our laundry
so we work and make more money so we can
pay people to do our laundry
um or let's say you work at starbucks
you're serving other people coffee but
on your rush to go to starbucks you have
to stop at you know dunkin donuts to buy
a coffee
we're just doing these sort of like uh
multi
like multi-part process of you know uh
servicing each other uh not in the only
fan's way um and i think
a lot of our economy especially the
white collar world is
structured like that in that when we're
staying home i think a lot of people are
cooking their own meals they're making
their own coffee and it's not that the
people selling that coffee
of the companies uh doing those sorts of
things are i don't consider them value
this i don't consider them [ __ ] jobs
to
uh make someone a breakfast sandwich but
it's like easily this sort of cut out
part of
the american economy as people are no
longer going the office
so i thought that was kind of
interesting what do you guys think
so i'm a huge proponent of remote work
and
i'm torn because as much as i love
remote work and i think that it's
better for the environment and better in
so many ways that i won't list right now
i also feel like it's sad that there are
so many businesses that are suffering so
i don't
i don't know i don't really i don't like
the idea that there are independent
shops that are closing because they
don't have people coming in for lunch
that they're the small stores or like
the little grocery corner market or
whatever
i i hate that so
i'm torn i don't know i don't have an
answer for that
yeah i mean i guess oh go ahead alec oh
well i was gonna say
i think there's a part of me when it
comes to
economic things right like jobs that
make us so busy
that we need uh to pay to get our
laundry done to make all of our meals
and all that stuff
like i think there's a part of me that's
like that is a
not a dumb part of the economy but
clearly uh useless in a sense that we're
making more money
to be able to pay for the things we
don't have time to do because our jobs
are so time consuming at the same time
that there's the human cost right and
it's the case of you know i don't want
anyone to be out of a job who's working
in midtown but i would say
uh you know maybe if there was some
social structure like a universal basic
income to like
we don't have to worry about that kind
of [ __ ] uh so like if i ever sound
heartless and
this sort of thing it is sort of with
that framework of yeah
like there's no reason we need to be
paying people to make all of our meals
for us
um at the same time i don't want the
people to suffer from that
yeah definitely and i think there's you
know not to get uh all political and
stuff
but when everything gets privatized it
creates more reasons for us to have
these these random industries doing
things that we didn't use to think we
needed people to do for us
and then like you pointed out alec when
we have
you know when we don't have universal
basic incomes or job guarantees or
whatever it creates these precarious
positions
where folks are dependent on on jobs
like that so it's
it's really rough and then i think it
just reminds me a little bit of um
i think there's a facebook commercial
right now about
i think it's real about a bar called
coogans
in uh new york and there's this old
irish looking guy who's running and
they're talking about this bar and how
it was a place where everyone felt
comfortable
and how if we don't support businesses
like that they're all going to fail
and you know it frames the entire
narrative
as like it's our personal responsibility
to save businesses that are failing
completely ignoring the larger economic
structures
that exist and create these problems and
i think the narrative around a lot of
this stuff is really unhelpful right now
especially and so much as it puts the
impetus on individuals
to fix these things yeah i have to go
get blackout drunk at my nearest bar
to make sure that my favorite bartender
doesn't end up homeless what a great
system we live in
yeah i mean there's a small local
restaurant group by restaurant group
they have like two places in my
neighborhood
and they've done a lot of during the
pandemic they pivoted to being like a
store and a market and having takeout
meals and all this stuff
and they put out an email this week that
was something like we're gonna be honest
with you guys
it's not going well if you have the
money to shop with us this week or order
dinner
it would be a big help um and i guess
even to touch back on my
my chat from this week you know what
that restaurant shutting down like these
things
are happening also can people hear the
lawn work happening outside my house
because i feel like i should maybe close
a window if not
i can hear but it's it's not it's not
very loud
okay sorry anyone and sorry to break the
flow of this conversation but i got very
self-conscious about that
sir what do you think um i
i i i feel like almost like like
physical pain
when business is closed even if it's a
large place like
if a nordstrom closes or like a chain
restaurant closes
i feel really bad about that not because
i
i feel bad for the corporation but
because of all the people who work there
that they all need to find a new job so
it i i hate it that's why i was like
puffing up my toffee place so much but i
don't
i don't know like i i work in the tech
industry and
um a lot of companies are remote
and i've been following a lot and what's
happening in san francisco like a lot of
uh like i think twitter or was it
pinterest
paid like 70 million dollars to get out
of their lease
so like the number of employees that
work in that building in san francisco
i can't imagine the impact that it'll
have on the local economy
but then i also think like if more
companies go remote
then maybe there are individuals in
developing countries who wouldn't have
access to um
a high income role now have access to it
because
the company's remote they're hiring all
over the world so
like it does hurt the local economy but
maybe it opens things up
and makes things more global and gives
somebody an opportunity who wouldn't
otherwise have that chance
yeah and i also i know we talked about
this before but i think
oftentimes when money and businesses are
uh centered in like a downtown area for
instance all the money during the day
flows there
and so there's really high rents that's
mostly you know the large
real estate conglomerates that own them
whereas you know i'm sure there's plenty
of people
who make lots of money in my
neighborhood who otherwise would be
commuting
and now they're going to go to like the
local neighborhood place for launch that
wasn't seeing that
so so like it's sort of decentralizing
where all the money goes
and a lot of the way our cities are
designed are for the sake of
centralization and i think that
centralization leads to like
a lot of this like very gross
stratification of you know
billion-dollar real estate conglomerates
versus you know
the family that maybe owns a building in
my neighborhood yeah
i think what worries me a little bit
about this and this kind of maybe
touches on what you you were saying
serbia with you know pinterest shutting
down in san francisco or
wherever they are in the bay this vision
of a world where there's like two
classes of people
the one group that has like tech remote
jobs and lives in these like
weird high-end apartments that have like
co-living and working spaces
and another group of people that spends
all day driving around delivering food
groceries medicine clothes whatever and
we just sort of have those
two worlds where you have like your tech
remote job and you sit down all day and
your back gets really [ __ ] up because
you're not going outside or doing
anything
or you're just driving around in the
streets all day delivering [ __ ] i think
we already see that like i've seen a bit
of that
um oh i can't say that because it's
about my neighbors and by any chance
they see this they'll be mad at me
but there's i just see a lot of this in
in my neighborhood
and my world where it does feel like
there's those two
worlds forming and i find that
worrisome yeah and and when the only
jobs available
you know are like instacart or something
like that
you know and that's no no hate on anyone
that does that i've good friends that
have worked at instacart
but it like doesn't sound great and it
doesn't sound like they're treating
people well and i think especially when
things were worse
uh in the pandemic it was just sort of
like wow there's like
a group of people that hasn't had to
leave their house because they're
sending strangers
into like hazardous situations to do
stuff for them
because they can pay for it and i guess
so so maybe i'm being a little dystopian
but the extension of of the remote work
plus service economy world freaks me out
totally
now that's all i've got uh i want to
shout out chris tomski for donating who
says
thanks chris a similar issue with
recycling i think he's talking about
our responsibility to go get blackout
drunk at our bar
uh chris says there's similar issue with
recycling corporations switched to cheap
disposable plastic then campaigned to
push the blame onto individuals to
recycle
i think that's apt yeah also alec why
does everything have to be out bars with
you why is everything about drinking
sorry i don't even try um i know that's
why it's fun
um i'm not an alcoholic like you
hold on i need some more of water yeah
uh
um what's your topic what do you want to
talk about oh what don't i want to talk
about um
someone talk about music not that that's
a shock i always any time i can i think
music and sports are the two things
anytime i can find an angle for those i
want to talk about it
but i want to talk about something so
there's an article that came out earlier
in um you know the pandemic timeline uh
by
jeremy d larson who i think is the
reviews editor at pitchfork
pitchfork which kind of sucks sometimes
but they have some really good writers
that work there so you know
both sides um and then recently they did
a podcast episode
discussing the article and the article
is entitled why do we even listen to new
music
and in the article larson is making the
argument
for why listening to new music isn't
just interesting at a cultural level
it can have a positive neurological
effect on us on the flip side it gets
into
why our brain is structured to reward us
in an immediate sense for just listening
to [ __ ] that we've already heard
or things that sound like stuff we've
already listened to
and in particular i think the the
article is relevant because
we're living in a world where a lot of
people aren't having a lot of new
external stimuli
they're staying in their houses talking
to the same people re-watching
the office or community or whatever it
might be um
and i found it really interesting so
there are a few quotes from it i wanted
to get into
um so the first is he says this in the
article
when it comes to hearing music a network
of nerves in the auditory cortex called
the
i'll probably say this wrong um
corticofugal network helps catalog the
different patterns of music
when a specific sound maps onto a
pattern our brain releases a
corresponding amount of dopamine
the main chemical source of some of our
most intense emotions
so one of the ideas there is that as we
listen to music in our formative years
we have networks in our brain that when
we hear stuff that
is that or sounds like that our brain is
like yeah here's some of that good stuff
um so it sort of rewards us um and
the article quotes um jonah lehrer who
in his book proust or proust is it it's
proust right
i think so sorry yeah proust was a
neuroscientist
he says the essential joy of music comes
in our songs subtly toy with patterns in
our brains spiking the dopamine
more and more without sending it off the
charts so
you know we listen to music it creates
these patterns in our brains and often
we'll listen to music that's like
slightly removed so our brain patterns
still recognize it but it adds like a
little bit of novelty
and and kind of keeps us in that realm
but what happens when we listen to
something that's completely new
is it can kind of break our brain a
little bit
and this is another quote from the
article that says when there is no
anchor or no pattern on which to map
music registers as unpleasant or in
layman's terms
bad if the dopamine neurons can't
correlate their firing with outside
events
the brain is unable to make cogent
associations we go a bit
mad so listening to music
is both creating patterns and breaking
patterns
in our brains and our we have these sort
of networks for what we have heard
and i and that what it kind of gives an
interesting explanation is sometimes why
we're hesitant to listen to new stuff
um on the podcast where they talked
about this someone gave the example of
you know you're in a car with your
friend and your friend's like hey i want
you to listen to something
and as they play it they're staring at
you like right
right and you're just kind of like i
don't know like i guess
um because our brain is predisposed to
not want to
have a pleasurable um listening
experience so
um i'll read like two more quotes but
the article says the way the
corticofugal system learns new patterns
limits our experience by making
everything we already know far more
pleasurable than everything we don't
skipping ahead it's that our brains
actually fight against the unfamiliarity
of life
so our brain is going to reward us for
staying within patterns
it's going to almost like punish us or
make it hard
to push those experiences so one of the
closing quotes of the article
he says don't let don't let history be
recursively defined by a feedback loop
steer into the skid pour the fear and
dread leaking through your roof into
something unfamiliar
because it could become the new artifact
that exclusively defines this moment for
you a new friend who totally loves you
for what you've become
so one of the gist of the article ends
up being that you know what better time
than now to listen to new music to have
new experiences
um to let this be a time that we listen
to new things and don't just fall back
into the same patterns both for our
cultural enrichment but literally
for how our brain works um
so to you all i mean how how do you
experience
and we could say music or we could
broaden this out to other culture but in
recent months have you found yourselves
going back to like comforting classics
or
pushing the limits with new sounds what
have your music habits been like
recently
i uh i used to really hate 80s music i
thought it was corny i thought their
hair was dumb
and just had like a blanket and this is
like 14 year old alec that's saying this
um but recently i've you know loosened
up in my old age
and one of the bands that i've always
had sort of an irrational uh association
of disliking is the talking heads uh but
i actually saw the garage sale one of
the records and picked it up it's so
[ __ ] good
um yeah what this article really reminds
me of though
is uh have
sometimes guilty sometimes not love of
like a lot of metal music and i think
metal is like the best example
of someone who's never been exposed to
metal or just a little bit they're like
this sounds awful it is like grading to
my ears and it's because those like
neural connections literally aren't made
but as you listen to it more like oh
this is really good and sometimes
weirdly beautiful
and uh i'm glad at least that like i
went through
i think that painful process uh because
some of my favorite bands now like
between the beard and me is a great
great example for any like
music aficionado i would definitely uh
suggest looking into them because what
they do is like very interesting
um but they specifically do like a
balance of like very discordant very
like melodic beautiful things
um and like with a lot of technicality
to it um but also
there's a really great if anyone else is
interested more on this concept i didn't
realize this is what you're talking
about michael but
uh a while ago radiolab did a podcast
episode about this and they talk about
uh this concept but also stravinsky's
right of spring
yes the article gets into that really
well actually yeah yeah so stravinsky
wrote this piece of music which is very
discordant very sort of
grading on the ears unless you're sort
of used to it um
would almost call it like a little proto
metal uh
and when it first performed uh i think
the story's true but maybe it's
apocryphal but the legend is that it
started
uh a riot um but their theory to it is
what people got kicked out of the
theater that night for fighting
yeah and so part of the theory is like
especially you know now we're surrounded
by a million kind even if you don't like
metal
you you've been exposed to metal you've
been exposed to dubstep you've been
exposed to taylor swift and kanye like
all these different things
whereas like back in the day if you
basically knew like
mozart and beethoven people that sound
like that things that like follow a very
specific formula and here's this sort of
in your face thing
rio basically hypothesized like it was
setting their brains on fire and they
had to fight it out
um i'll put a i'll put a link to that in
the chat in case anyone's interested i
did
uh find it real quick what do you think
serbia
so during the pandemic i've been
listening to
uh things that i wouldn't normally
listen to
um and what's interesting to me is that
i feel like any guy that i date um
i always feel like i don't like their
music like the music that they're
interested in
at all and i'm always like oh that again
like listening to that again
and then i feel like as time goes on i'm
like okay i'm into it
so with my last boyfriend um he he lives
in europe so he's really into
like uh what is it like edm or
techno or whatever um and i couldn't
stand it like
like we be making breakfast and it's
pumping in the back
we're about to go to bed it's pumping in
the back
um but now i've been watching live
streams of like
artists in belgium and it's interesting
like i
enjoy listening to it while i work so
it makes a lot of sense to me because i
didn't know why that i was why i was so
interested in it i was like is this like
a weird like
remnant of our relationship where i want
to listen to it
but i don't think it is i mean i think i
genuinely enjoy it now
yeah that's hey the benefits of of
relationships we can look back on the
music we learned along the way
um go ahead alec well that's good this
is broader than music but do you guys
i've been noticing this recently
sometimes i'll get i'll call it like a
culture rut where i'm not watching
anything new i'm not even reading
anything new
maybe i'm playing the same video game uh
like over and over again
and i feel like it makes me depressed
and then i'll start going on a weird
library binge of books and be like i
feel great again i don't know if you
have a similar experience whether it's
tv shows or books or music or anything
like that
oh god yes and that's often like one of
my first amateur
mental health worker pieces of advice
for friends who are
feeling low level depressed or in a rut
sort of like hey when's the last time
you
read a new book or listened to new music
or watched the film by a filmmaker you
haven't seen before or something like
that and i do think it can shake things
up
um and like i know in my own life and
this is something i talked about this
like over a year ago
on culture binge um and this is
something i think i've mentioned a few
times
i've gotten really into the music and
culture around the grateful dead in the
past
16 months or so and it happened
basically completely by accident me
going to a concert with friends to see
some other artists there being a band
that featured one of the surviving
members of the grateful dead
me hearing this music i never heard
before me like well that's kind of cool
then going to a dead in company concert
the surviving members
of the grateful dead plus pop heartthrob
john mayer and some others
um but through that i think like the
past year of my life
it's been invigorating because i've been
not only learning about like
their music but the music that inspired
it and reading books about the history
and culture and that led me to learning
more about like
the early psychedelic movement and
everything around that and that
all came through hearing some new music
and music that for most of my life if
you would have been like you know what
the grateful dead i'd be like that
[ __ ] hippie [ __ ]
um which was like stupid to me i fell
into this pattern of rejecting that
and it's even the friends who i was at
that were at that show
those shows with um shout outs to baron
felipe uh
it's been a really cool experience for
us to like get more into that
music and i think in general that's you
know something i miss so much now is
live music because that's such a great
chance to experience something new where
often there's things i'll see
live and be like whoa what is this and
then listen to it where i think if i if
someone
just sent me this song i might not be as
compelled by it
yeah um and i know just i mean guys real
quickly like things that i can think of
besides
the music of the grateful dead um that
i've tried to listen to that's been
interesting recently um you know a lot
of more like
experimental and hip-hop influence
contemporary jazz i like a lot in
particular the music of this
artist michaia mcraven who put out a new
record during pandemic he's a drummer
jazz musician producer makes really
really cool music
and there's a british guitarist and like
producer named tom i think it's mish
m-i-s-c-h
um who does kind of like jazzy hip-hoppy
music which i like a lot
i also started listening to some more
like country folk stuff in particular
um gillian welch put out a new
collection of older songs and i haven't
listened to that type of music for a
while
and the last thing that's been kind of
helping expand my brain i've been
reading this book on playing changes by
nate chinnin who's a jazz writer and i
think is the
jazz critic for the new york times and
there's an accompanying playlist
for the book he put on spotify with all
types of jazz from the past like 40
years
some of it which immediately i like some
of which i hear and i'm like this kind
of sucks but i make myself listen to
because i trust him and he wrote about
it but it's all been really interesting
and i just think
there i'm gonna probably butcher this
but there was a stat from a study a
while ago that was like most people
don't like listen to new music past the
age of 27
and like that sucks and i don't want to
be that person who
you know years down the road i'm still
just listening to that so
also if you're in the chat too i would
love to hear what people are listening
to
um what sort of stuff uh that's helped
you
you know expand your brain during this
time so we got one
from uh craig bear who donated so thank
you but check out polka dot stingray
japanese math rock
break your music slump i don't know if
he means math
core is math rock different than math
core because i think math core is a
version of grind core which
might be directed yeah i think they're
different when i think of like math rock
i think like battles and sort of more
like technically
precise kind of chaotic music yeah
you're saying a lot of words yeah
no i like math rock a lot um but yeah i
don't know
not that we're here to give anyone
advice but in general like i don't know
listen to something new this week
why not also if anyone's listening this
in college uh
i took one music history class in high
school and one in college and
they were probably some of the best
that's the only music
course i took it's like some of the best
uh stayed with me
is incredibly valuable and just in being
a human and like when there's free
concerts in the park like oh
i recognize franzlis because i learned
about him a decade ago and
i understand why he's kind of cool and
interesting and also like
[ __ ] a bunch of people's wives which
is also kind of interesting
yeah i took a literature in jazz class
and
all of the uh texts that we read were
inspired by jazz or included jazz
elements
and i think my favorite one was sunny's
blues by james baldwin
um so it's written like a jazz piece
so highly recommend that that's great
well yeah
listen to new stuff read new stuff and
when the world opens back up
you know take some psychedelics and go
see some jazz i don't know
if that's if that's for you it'll be a
great time yeah
and listen listen to icp's rendition of
like mishimars which is the mozart song
do not no it's a great it's a classical
piece uh
made adapted in the 21st century i think
jack white is involved
too somehow listen to it yeah oh and
yeah
last shout out i don't know also i think
maybe song exploder is a fun thing to
listen to if like you want to get a new
music
go check out the song exploder podcast
pick an artist you haven't heard before
and listen to them break down a song in
a weird way and maybe that'll help i
don't know listen to new stuff
and tell us what you like um so
well i'm gonna move on any final
thoughts on this one that's all i got
great so before we move into the segment
of the show where we beg you to tell us
things write us
call us and then get into that quick
note on the last episode
um we talked about um
we got into the question of people
returning to disney parks in the midst
and midst of a pandemic and we ended up
like riffing a bit
about disney adults and we ended up
pissing some people
off um quite a few people i think more
than we were thinking
so we just wanted to make clear right
now if you're only watching this because
we pissed you off last time and you're
waiting to hate us even more
we have no issues with adults going to
disney
who love disney who participate in that
culture we are all
adults who nerd out about different
things like whether that's
um pokemon or music or video games or
certain types of literature we're all
obsessed with like obscure cultural [ __ ]
that we
nerd out about um we're not trying to
police anyone's fun
we're just having a bit of hyperbolic
and sarcastic fun and i think because we
all
like riffing with each other there's
times where maybe some of our
sarcasm is a little too dry i know i've
been accused in the past of being way
too dry in my tone
um so we just want to say we genuinely
apologize to anyone who was annoyed or
hurt by that discussion
um and thanks to everyone who reached
out to us about it we appreciate it like
let us know if we piss you off um we
want to be in dialogue with you
we'd love to hear your thoughts even
when you hate us and just know like we
love you more than simbo loves his dead
dad
so all the disney heads you have a home
here and like ninety percent i think of
the hate was
uh well meaning and constructive and i
was appreciative of that and ten of it
ten percent of it was batshit uh but
i it's funny because some of the
responses i was trying to
basically not humiliate myself but like
listen i'm a [ __ ] dude who likes
pokemon and it's like not that different
but
like you're such a hypocrite how dare
you say that and so i think that was
misconstrued and maybe i didn't
communicate clearly enough if anything
pokemon's more embarrassing
than being really into digital yeah so i
don't know why you got animal slaves
anyway
yeah uh i think my whole point and maybe
i also didn't sign post this correctly
was i think there's a level of
engagement with any fandom whether it's
uh
marvel or uh rick and morty or or disney
where a level of engagement and
attachment where you're not able to sort
of critically look at that thing and
that's
that's the thing that i will always
stand by criticizing right if you
are so enamored by disney and this isn't
a lot of people that you can't see
the larger structure of like why the
disney's a corporation kind of sucks
it might be a thing or uh you know if
i'll just leave it at that yeah no
things we like can get problematic go
ahead serbia i was so sad
when this happened i didn't want to do
the podcast anymore i was
crying i was so sad i'm like oh my gosh
i can't believe people
are upset and i contributed to their
unhappiness
so i'm i'm really sorry i didn't mean to
say anything that was unkind
and i love harry potter as much as you
love disney so i should have been more
compassionate and empathetic and
it served as a good reminder that that
we say things
and we should try to remember that there
is
there are people listening and our humor
doesn't always translate
our comments don't always translate and
so i'm very very sorry okay we don't
need to get too apologetic here
we're fine we're fine i'm not doing it i
don't stand by
that we did a fine job let's move on um
and like 50 cents once
50 cent one said uh when haters hate let
him hate and watch the money pile up
um so if you when you do hate us or you
do love us we love to hear from you and
the way you can get in touch with us is
hit us up at culturebinge
wisecrack.co always no m i don't know
who's at wisecrack.com they're probably
monsters
culture binge wisecrack.com and then you
can call us at 213-534-8807 once again
that's 213-534-8807
um and i know we have a voicemail uh
we're going to listen to maybe some
emails
uh alec would know better than i so
let's get into it
what's up this is a voicemail for
culture binge
i just wanted to make some comments on
the disney thing
i was in a dinner group with some
millennial
folks and two one of the couples
hosted a disney podcast which is pretty
popular i guess
and i think that uh in regards to
community
i think that there's a lot of
cooperating
communities within disney circles
especially people who are like deep into
it i think there's a lot of ticket
sharing and information swapping
i don't think it's kind of on like
reddit
subreddits and stuff like that like i
think there is that but i think that's
more for
like i don't know fantasy and
rick and morty stuff discussion pages
but anyway i just want to say that i
think there is a community
i think my issue this is coming from
someone who's a floor
used to be a food to floridian that my
issue is
like with disney itself i'm a huge
tolkien fan and the tolkien estate has
their problems especially with like
preserving like this idea
of canon but i think that disney
promotes this
weird dominant open canon for like all
these different
enterprises and um and ios
and stuff were i don't know the right
term anyway you know what i'm saying
like this open but only for them so that
they can make a billion dollars and then
cut everyone out so [ __ ] disney but
i can understand the cooperating uh fan
communities and i respect it
uh anyway this is nick from nashville
keep doing what you're doing love
culture [ __ ] love wisecrack
many smooches thank you so much nick
from nashville smooch is back to you and
always nice to hear from another person
who got out of florida
yeah um and yeah i i uh
no nothing to add other than i i agree
and that's why i said smooches back to
him
uh we we we got a lot of emails
um mostly about disney and alter ego
service topic
this alter ego one i think it stirred a
lot of people things about furries and
my
my precursor to the furry conversation
is i feel like in in my mind
there's two communities that i think
started off as like jokes on the
internet that i feel like are making a
cultural redemption
and those are jugglers and furries and
that's all i'm going to leave it there
but i'm going to read this comment
uh people can argue with me on the chat
uh
there's an email from chris uh long time
wisecrack fan love all the shows and
podcasts been playing to write in a few
times but always forget
uh serbia brought the topic of alter
egos and the benefits of assuming these
alternate identities i have to say it
scratches the surface of a very deep
piece of the role of identity in the
furry fandom
i've been a furry myself around 15 years
and like many it was a means to explore
an alternate identity as a route to
acceptance of being gay
for lots of people in the fandom role
and i don't mean typing
as a character allows them to tackle
through issues like sexuality or mental
health it also extends beyond that
oftentimes they pick a character that
represents an idealized version of
themselves acting out what they
what or who they want to be is fairly
effective means to actualize that desire
in my case i play a bit of a cocky but
fun otter that hosts awesome pool
parties i've seen
every variation of identity from wanting
to be the know it all nerd to the dumb
but lovable
jock who'd want to never mind uh
i'll get back to that in a second no
longer fearing the cringe furries near
uh being near the bottom of the internet
subculture barrel after all
they can feel confident to branch into
other communities often mocked like punk
goth and otaku
over time though those traits become
natural and if hopefully you are
maintained plenty of connections with
friends
colleagues and family outside the fandom
you adopt the alter ego as an improved
part of your identity as a whole
all in all i've had had my alter ego aka
fursona for about half my life now and i
really can't imagine life without it
that's awesome uh i didn't know i didn't
realize that that was a lot of
of what goes into that and that's really
rad now and it's changed the way
i view that and that all sounds so cool
i also think uh
not just that community but like a lot
of i think a lot of the more like
marginalized communities on the internet
are like a a good place for like people
on the spectrum who are like oh i'm
different and also like these people
identify
with being different and so that's cool
and i feel safe here and can maybe like
do things
um but it does i can't uh this person
asked me not to read this email but
thank you this person for writing this
email
i got a very long email about like fan
fiction and like shipping and like rick
and morty incest porn and lots of things
it was very good email
um but i think again with the furry
thing like it there's like gradations of
uh what level of this is like what
might be called like a maladaptive
coping strategy versus like a healthy
one and so this person used the example
of a person on the internet who
um basically had an emotional affair
with their partner because they created
like a persona on the internet to act
out and had a relationship with someone
else's persona and they're like it's not
cheating it's fiction
uh and so that doesn't seem cool
uh and yeah be critical of these things
but not
be an [ __ ] about them what are your
thoughts on that email
i i really enjoyed this email i really
want to go to one of his pool parties
i am so supportive of the furry
furry dumb is that what it's called um
the furry community
um and i just remembered i need to
respond to one of our patrons
we were supposed to talk about furries
in a dm so if you become a patron
you can dm us on our discord uh
also a person in the comments noted that
one of the guys from icp
uh their daughter's a furry and he being
a supportive dad went to a furry
convention
and oh sick yeah supportive dad
supportive parents yeah
um all right here they exist here is an
email
from i want to make sure it's the sorry
person
uh bria
about disney hi culture binge crew
before i get into disney adulting i just
want to say i'm glad that finally
somebody said slack is the worst thing
to ever happen
you're welcome whoever said that i think
it was serbia okay so i'm just here uh
i'm just okay so i'm sure you're going
to get a lot of emails on this topic but
i'm not here to
just explain i don't like to consider
myself a disney adult but i am a huge
disney fan
amongst my friends and i uh sorry
amongst my friends and i we consider
disney adults to be people who spend
excessive amounts of time
or of money on anything disney related
which is fine but the worst is those who
lose their mind whenever disney changes
something about the parks mostly themes
of the rides
and or those who treat disney as if it's
actually a family company with wholesome
values that has everyone's best interest
in mind
i'm fully aware of the monopolizing
monster that the walt disney company
is and maybe for that you'll think that
i'm even worse for staying a fan but i'm
not a fan of the company especially not
of the new ceo or the recent ceo i'm a
fan of disney movies characters and
parks i grew up going to disneyland i'm
now in my 20s and still have
that love and wonder in my heart so i do
often get emotional when i meet mickey
mouse or watch one of those live shows
my
favorite characters i also want to speak
to what michael said about
it being at kids park though it's
marketed towards family actually caters
heavily to adults
disneyland itself is still mainly for
kids and families but across the way
there's california adventure
there's alcohol and literally every
corner and there's a few rides that
don't have height requirements
the bigger uh the bigger scarier rides
are there as for disney world and
florida magic kingdom is their
disneyland but i quite enjoyed damaging
my liver at epcot
the point is i still yes i still feel
the magic as i fell as a child whenever
i go to disney park and i love meeting
my favorite characters and love going on
rides
their shows are especially fun to watch
and the alcohol quite tasty
uh yeah that's from bria thank you bria
thanks bria epcot rules we should have
got into that
um epcot rules you can do the whole walk
around all the different countries
and get food and drinks with them and
this is going to sound corny but
remember that i spent my formative
teen years in orlando where there wasn't
a lot of culture i like learned about
japanese food because of epcot like i
never would have like
truly like had a version of real
japanese food and learned about it if i
didn't go to the epcot
around the world yeah i think of epcot
as the adult one and they do a food and
wine festival every year
where you can go and get all this food
and drink and just get real smashed
there
um but once again it's not all about
drinking but that's a great email
uh the last one comes from kevin again
about disney
uh high culture binge crew in the most
recent episode of culture binge the crew
discussed disney adults in the reopening
of disney world during the pandemic
it seems this may have led to some
polarized and frustrated reaction from
some listeners
and i want to share my thoughts in order
to consider multiple perspectives i'm
going to use a dialectical approach we
love that word
kevin yeah
michael actually did this when he was
discussing how he could see it both ways
but i wonder if this comment was
overlooked by listeners reacting to the
harsher comments that michael made
i think so uh which i felt were
primarily meant as jokes but
perhaps we're not understood as such by
frustrated listeners i love this person
disclaimer that i'm trained to be a
psychologist not a philosopher and thus
my understanding of dialectics comes
from an approach called dialectical
behavior therapy called dbt
uh while i might personally find the
idea of being a disney adult stupid i
also think that there are a lot of other
childish things that adults can find
meaning enjoyment within
alec mentioned pokemon serbia had
mentioned harry potter for michael
perhaps reality dating shows
for me i've always recently spent a lot
of free time playing final fantasy video
games since the release of final fantasy
7 remake
i've heard great things jared's a big
fan uh anyway uh my main point is
in all this is to say that we like what
we like as adults and sometimes those
things are childish and may seem stupid
to others i think it is important for us
to
as individuals to acknowledge these
conflicting truths in some sense playing
file fantasy video games is kind of
childish and stupid but it's also been a
really positive thing for me that helps
me feel
better right now both of those things
can be okay and i'm not going to get
upset at a friend who doesn't find the
same level of meaning enjoyment in these
games as i do
if they were to make a joke about it to
me i would do my best to remind myself
that they're not trying to be mean or
hurtful just poking fun
know that this is always easier said
than done so for all the disney adults
out there we love you and it's okay to
get excited emotional about your
interest in disney but i do think it's
also important to be
to be able to admit to yourself and
others that you're participating in
something that's primarily meant for
kids and then
can this be appropriately described as
childish
both of those things can be true uh i
think that this was the overall point
made by culture bridge crew so i might
not be saying anything new but perhaps
putting this in different words might
help people
feel a little bit better now uh yeah i
love this email because i think
uh that's what i was trying to i i think
kevin basically
said a smarter version of what we were
sort of fumbling around which is that
uh we can both be critical of the things
we love and also hold that we love them
dearly like
disney's an evil corporation and you
still might love
the star wars franchise that they own uh
or i [ __ ] love star trek and the
first season of picard is
dog [ __ ] but i'm still gonna keep
watching it um or i do lots of things
that
are dumb and ridiculous such as playing
pokemon go and occasionally spending
money on it
uh but i can still i could still like it
the those both of those things can be
true
kevin rules i'm excited for anyone who
works as a psychologist because you're
going to be the best
and it's always great when someone can
take our rambling
20-minute discourse and be like oh cool
here's like the logical
dialectical structure of what they were
getting at i'd really appreciate
that if i could like send kevin a beer
or coffee or smoothie or beverage of his
choosing i would so thank you so much
for that email
uh do we have time for one more or is it
time to wrap up
we're a little over an hour but we could
we could just do it and we could cut it
later if we need to
sure uh all right uh this last one
is from [ __ ]
i didn't write their name but they're
gonna recognize their own email uh
hey wisecrack uh so last week michael
talked about uh
a composer that you forgot their name
but they were an insurance
agent or something like that yes and
yeah yeah a very avant-garde
uh basically became well-known after
they died uh
the the person wrote and say the
american composer michael couldn't
remember was charles ivey and yes he
owned a successful insurance company
he had only limited recognition in his
lifetime and composed his spare time as
a hobby
his music being very experimental and
pulling musical techniques that would
become commonplace in 20th century
avant-garde music
regarding your statement that monetizing
your art leads to loss of control and
expression that speaks to my own
experience as a musician for most of the
20s i played in bands and taught music
conformally and was eventually
able to live on the income however when
i began thinking of where to go next
how to take my career to the next level
i realized that i have to start making
decisions based on what other people i
an audience want to see or hear i also
began hearing and seeing more of the
upper regions of the music business and
realized the unpleasant things that
musicians do
or are expected to do in order to get
ahead i realized that these factors
would inhibit my creativity enjoyment of
the music
this is why i became a high school music
teacher because i can help young people
make music all day
be paid a decent salary and pursue the
musical projects that i feel have value
and not
compromise these values based on the
need for positive regard from strangers
hunter s thompson sent a letter to a
friend that a person shouldn't shape
themselves to fit their goals but rather
shape their goals to suit them i think
this is the best summary of success i've
come across
keep making great wow thank you for just
an anonymous person
that was great that's rad thanks for all
my memory and also
that's so that's just great becoming
high school music teacher i literally
last night
i hadn't read this email was talking
with my partner about how awesome
music teachers are and how it sucks that
that many schools have gotten rid of
them
it's such an important thing and the
work you're doing is rad so thank you so
much
yeah i also uh the school i went to had
like a very
prominent jazz school and 99 of those
people are
just music teachers now uh and they
still do all their cool music on the
side but if you want to go to jazz
school that's probably what you'll be
doing so just just be aware of that
yeah um awesome well so thank you so
much to everyone who wrote and called
wrote in and called in um and if you
haven't done it yet do it soon
if we made you mad or glad this episode
or if you were able to
pick through our incoherent ramblings to
get at the logical core of it
like a good german idealist or something
um hit us up and let us know at
culturebinge wisecrack.comnom
or 213-534-8807 we really appreciate it
means a lot to us and the dialogue on
the show whether it's in the chat
or in the calls even if you don't always
agree with us means a lot to us and we
know that
we hope you all know that you're a part
of this and a part of the conversation
and we hope you stay that way um so
we're going to wrap up now
but as always if you want to find us or
yell at us online
you need to know where to do that so
serbia if someone wants to
hit you up and let you know that that
you're absolutely right about only fans
and an ally to that community where can
they do it
sir patel 22 on twitter yes alec if
someone wants to let you know
that as the ceo of some i don't know
like
delivery service for contract laborers
that you're wrong
where can they let you know on on
twitter at wisecrack alec
awesome um and if you want to tell me
that the only good music is
pop music and everything else is trash
on twitter with that said we'll be back
in a couple weeks thank you so much for
listening thank you for everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you